safe in the surroundings of an English
park and northern 2,000 miles from the
dangers of their Syrian homeland el
Hassan Hassan but there's no escape from
the memories in an exhibition of
pictures drawn by refugee children the
mental scars are all too clear this one
features an imaginary life beyond war in
which the child asks Oh God when will my
dream come true but as this family have
discovered escaping the war is one thing
for getting it is another one of us at
the Y Ariana seven-year-old Allah tells
us that even in the UK it's sometimes
hard to feel safe we used to be scared
of aeroplanes and here there are lots of
airplanes she says when we get scared
mom and dad huggers that's a little man
her brother has saying who's 9 says I
used to think the planes would hitters
that it would drop a bomb and hitters
planes drop bombs and bombs explode and
people die psychologists in Manchester
are attracting international interest in
a program to help the children of war
believing that those who managed to
escape rarely do so without mental scars
they've been through a whole series of
extremely difficult experiences and will
have served for their lives and these
sorts of experiences really leave marks
on people and the first line of defense
for children really is having parents
who are able to help them through so we
want to be able to give parents a very
specific advice on how to help their
children with particularly with trauma
related concerns because they still fear
reprisals against relatives in Syria
these parents prefer to remain anonymous
and it's not only can mine our mob clean
I'm over noon but they tell us the
children were mostly scared at night
they saw everything they saw my sister's
husband in his plant with his wounds
they saw everything the Sibyl solar i
did a holla when they first arrived here
their father says they were very scared
of planes at policemen and anyone in
uniform because over there it's fair
different regarding uniformed people
we're safer here gradually they're
getting better honey nobody expects them
to forget the memory of war but slowly
they are learning that there's no need
to be suspicious all the time and the
tear of planes don't always carry bombs
Mike McCarthy Sky News Manchester